incremental auth is a feature of google
plus site that allows you to ask users
for commissions as you need to users who
are new to your app may hesitate when
being asked to grant multiple
commissions up front however if they see
these requests when it makes sense they
can better understand how their data
will be used asking for consent in
context may reduce friction lead to more
completed sign in and a more engaged
audience take a look at eight tracks
when I first signed in I was asked for
only the permissions they need to get me
started now that I found out that they
can recommend music based on my favorite
YouTube channels when they asked me for
permission to access YouTube it makes
sense before I know it I'm listening to
music recommended to me by eight tracks
and it can be easier check out our
developer Docs to learn how simple it is
to have incremental auth to your apps